salut tout montrer
ce n'est pas pouvoir rester avec sa
tournée sur merci d'être avec nous aussi
déguiser pour halloween alors aussi
beaucoup posé la question est ce qu on
se déguisait ce qu'on déguise pas et
puis après on sait chauffer et quand
vous allez voir les déguisements servir
mois en fait j'ai le déguisement le plus
pouilles
je viens de passer quand même de voir
regarde copain à moi ici qui me fait
waouh pas mal il m'a non plus que la
baguette le magicien il a même pas
remarqué jettent en dracula donc pour
vous dire je suis le pire de tous mais
vous allez voir les chroniqueurs ce soir
et je peux vous dire là dans un instant
vous allez être impressionné par les
costumes
je vais demander à valérie bénaïm qui a
le deuxième costume le plus pourri de
venir valérie bénaïm c'est la deuxième
plus pourris ou à la chine
franck et jeanne des conquois
frankenstein et pourquoi pas oui mais
parce qu'il fait très très peur sur gaël
fait tripper il suffit pour tous pas non
mais tu fais peur voilà merci à l'est
benjamin castaldi regarder al baraka
samedi exceptionnel oh là là là là c'est
bien ton quoi beetlejuice se soient pas
vains calme-toi mais toi là-bas merci
calme-toi mais toi là-bas allaetin can i
vé d'ovni kelly vdev dit aulas oui
ah oui alors
les caméras sont là merci vous êtes en
quoi ça soit pas non plus en plus de
chats plan de bouchons mais chapeau
rouge qui fait recours vous avez parrot
non beaucoup répond vraiment aux
questions peut on y voir le matin
regarder quand les clients vont le voir
à la mi-temps kouaoua où le fils
d'yvette horner
le clown ça ouais d'accord mais c'est
fou parce que fischer s'est fait comme
ça mais sans doute sortir dehors comme
ça dans la rue
faut le faire moi j'adore ça mais je
suis je veux lui faire perdre voilà oui
s'il ya quelqu'un qui le prend sur lui
avant la fin de l'année chose que mes
deux les vingt dernières minutes près si
tu vas te pro stock sur la tête de ma
mère ou sa peluche ou auteurs avaient
rappelé quelques trucs à seniors tu sais
quoi
il ya un mec qui te feront stop et voilà
on le dit on redouble on nous pousse à
l'air ce soir
eh ben je sors tout à l'heure si elle
peut sortir
merci et vous vous vous non non non je
suis reçue mais ça dans good fait moins
peur lui il est vraiment bref allez on
va accueillir lille qui s'appelle morini
bosc et la halle et isabelle morini-bosc
soie et de la moitié des voûtes fédérer
mais c'est
pire c'est que c'est audrey naturel non
mais non mais c'est hyper belge te jure
franchement bravo bébé a vu la belle
allée on a on a quelques jours delphine
wespiser delphine wespiser away baudoux
ce beau des liens ouais ouais bah ouais
bah merci vous êtes ont foi en allah bin
ouais c'est vrai alors allah dans la
danse or la danse
après des films wespiser bien entendu
qui suit souvent derrière bien sûr jean
michel maire merci jour un gars mettant
quoi occuper d'euros on compte des
bêtises fethi de poids ont dû me dégoûte
pas encore un héron claudine la méthode
la famille addams bas mais toi derrière
merci merci c'est mal aller vers cela
merci relâche que plus je peux plus il
reste qu'il arrivait à maxime guaino une
kia maxime guennoun ah oui ah oui mais
lotus la taupe et ça hyper bientôt si je
joue beaucoup sur maxime gagny
magnifiques costumes au maquillage
formidable et il nous restera alors
alors pour moi c'est le meilleur c'est
gilles verdez
ah ouais vous allez allez faire du stop
sous les 2 g toi t'as pas besoin de
faire un loup fin on sait que je crie la
pop et maléfique
vous imaginez vous avez ça chez vous
sans rigoler redemander fatma part hier
de son côté mace vas-y tu nous regardes
a dit cherry mon amour veux tu m'épouser
fin h
on me dit que non il reste géraldine
alémany feature malawi girondine est à
la fois moi oui je suis la reine de
magnifiques
je suis choqué je suis choqué et déçu
son ciblage et d'amour tu es somptueux
en elle même à l'attenté de bella je
peux éviter à la barre on vous entend
pas mais vous êtes très sympathique
dans un instant voilà ceux ci on vous
envoie faire du stop tous les deux si
vous avez des armes et des 2100 rigoler
avez vous et moi et franchement je sais
c'est quoi ces deux fêtes mais je me
demande si lui fait pas plus peur que
lui tient dit mme thibout qui nous fait
le plus peur dans l'équipe
voilà moi pour moi pour moi c'est
raymond benhaim benhaim elf europe mais
genre à sera d'accord comprend pas le
délire en fait